NoNous voici avec notre panel
popolitique, Michel David, Michl
C.C. Auger et Christian Dufour.
B Bonsoir Monsieur.
- - Bonsoir.
OnOn se serait attendu un débatn
pepeu plus élevé la journée même
dede la commémoration de la mort
dede Joyce Echaquan au salon bl.
LeLe principe de Joyce, pour que
leles gens comprennent bien
l'l'extrait qu'on va entendre,
c'c'est le chef de Manawan qui a
didit qu'il faut reconnaître un
cecertain nombre de choses, il a
enentre autres le racisme
sysystémique. Mais c'est pas
l'l'essence. C'est plutôt une mn
tetendue pour dire qu'il faut qe
nonos deux nations s'entendent
mimieux. On écoute un échange qi
a a dérapé à l'Assemblée
nanationale.
- - Pour ça, il nous faut
cocollectivement franchir
unune étape, celui de reconnaîte
lele principe de Joyce. Je demae
auau premier ministre qu'on puie
poposer ce geste aujourd'hui.
- - Monsieur le président,
jeje suis d'accord avec
lele principe de Joyce.
LLà où j'ai un problème,
c'c'est quand on voit une vidéo
dudu député de Jacques-Cartier
ququi fait un amalgame
enentre Joyce Echaquan...
- - Je suis outré que le premier
miministre choisisse cette
ququestion-là, cette question-là
susur le principe de Joyce,
susur la réalité que vivent les
pepeuples autochtones au Québec,
susur la réalité que vivent
ceces sept enfants-là, pour
s's'en prendre à la conduite
d'd'un député qui n'a absolument
ririen à se reprocher,
MoMonsieur le président.
- - Quand j'entends le député de
RoRobert-Baldwin, quand j'entens
lala députée de Saint-Laurent,
MoMonsieur le président, même ps
lalaisser le premier ministre
rérépondre à sa question, il y a
unun enjeu et c'est peut-être ç,
lele débat, Monsieur le préside.
- - Michel David, qu'est-ce que
vovous en avez pensé?
- - J'ai vu que la politique a
rerepris ses droits, ça n'a pas
étété long. Une journée où on
dedevrait avoir un peu plus
d'd'élévation. C'est le même dét
ququi revient sous une autre foe
susur le racisme systémique qui
dadate d'avant la mort de Joyce
EcEchaquan. Le premier ministre
c'c'est un peu peinturé dans le
cocoin depuis le début en disant
ququ'il n'y avait pas de racisme
sysystémique. J'ai toujours pené
ququ'il avait tellement accusé
PhPhilippe Couillard de vouloir
cuculpabiliser les Québécois qul
esest pris avec un discours quie
pepeut pas changer. J'ai pas vua
vividéo...
- - c'est une vieille vidéo du
momois de juin ou Kelly dit quee
gogouvernement a tendance à trop
ememployer la clause
didiscriminatoire. Mais c'est ue
vivieille vidéo du mois de juin.
- - Associé ce qui est arrivé à
MaMadame Joyce Echaquan à ça, iy
a a quelque chose qui ne marche
papas. J'ai toujours l'impressin
auaussi que dans le cas des
auautochtones, peut-être Monsier
LeLegault et beaucoup de Québécs
seseraient prêts à dire qu'il ya
efeffectivement du racisme
sysystémique. À partir du moment
ouoù on dit que les autochtones,
ininévitablement il faudrait
coconsidérer que les communautés
cuculturelles, il n'y a pas que
leles Première Nation. On peut s
didire aux autres, c'est vrai ls
auautres c'est pas vrai. Alors .
LeLegault est conséquent avec sn
dédéni.
- - On peut être totalement cone
cece qu'a dit Kelly dans une vio
auau mois de juin mais ce que
c'c'était le moment d'en parler?
- - Non, c'était pas le moment
d'd'en parler. Monsieur Legaultà
fafaire ça pris amalgame dans ç.
C'C'était pas la journée pour
fafaire ça. Ces temps-ci, M.
LeLegault sur ces questions-là,l
titire sur tout ce qui bouge.
DeDepuis qu'il a décidé qu'il
ététait le chef de la nation, il
titire nécessairement
lilittéralement sur tout ce qui
bobouge. On va voir si ça va lui
papasser. Une journée comme
auaujourd'hui, c'était pas
nénécessaire. Je pense que les
babaux de Michel David sur les
babancs, et c'est peinturé danse
cocoin. La plupart des Québécois
sosont capables de reconnaître
ququ'on a un problème de racisme
enenvers les autochtones au
QuQuébec. Il n'y a pas de systèe
mamagique racisme, mais il y a n
prproblème. La question de Joyce
EcEchaquan en est une preuve ily
enen a eu d'autres. C'est pas
ininutile à un moment donné de
nonommer les choses.
- - Christian, vous dîtes depuis
lele début qu'on va devenir foie
avavec ce débat-là. Comment vous
avavez reçu ça aujourd'hui?
- - J'ai trouvé sois triste que
l'l'attention soit diverti de
l'l'essentiel. L'essentiel, c'et
quque la mort de Joyce Echaquan
n'n'est pas passée inaperçue. On
lala commémore un an après. Je
susuis pas d'accord avec mes dex
cocollègues. Monsieur Legault
n'n'est pas peinturé dans le co.
JeJe pense qu'il s'oppose qu'ila
raraison de s'opposer fermementà
cece concept qui est
esessentiellement lié au néo
cuculturalisme canadien et à la
cuculture ou occupée. C'est pasn
coconcept neutre. On peut dénonr
tototalement le racisme à l'égad
dedes autochtones. C'était juste
leles autochtones, c'est... M.
LeLegault ne renoncera pas à ça.
DéDéjà, on voit du racisme
papartout. Imaginez cela Québec
s's'embarquant plus dans une
rereconnaissance formelle du
raracisme systémique. C'est un
coconcept essentiellement
popolitique.
- - Il ne pouvait dire : je suis
d'd'accord avec la principe de
JoJohn, la main tendue. Est-ce e
chchaque fois, celui qui était à
l'l'offensive aujourd'hui, c'étt
lului.
- - J'ai pas tout écouté, mais a
dédéclaration de Joyce, ça
cocomprend le racisme systémiqu.
MoMonsieur Legault ne veut pas
direre qu'il est d'accord avec .
MoMonsieur Legault n'acceptera
jajamais le racisme systémique,
ououbliant ça. Je pense que la
mamajorité des Québécois ne sont
papas d'accord avec cette
rereconnaissance là parce que ça
leles métros dans une situation
ilils ont l'air d'être raciste.
C'C'est dommage, parce que
l'l'essentiel n'est pas là.
L'L'essentiel c'est qu'il y a du
raracisme au Québec comme ailles
ilil faut le dénoncer.
- - Je n'aurais pas parlé
auaujourd'hui de racisme
sysystémique n'eus été de cet
écéchange à l'Assemblée nationa.
RaRacisme systémique, pour ou
cocontre, on parlait de la
dédéclaration de Joyce
auaujourd'hui.
- - Il y a des gens qui ne sont
papas des farfelues, qui ne sont
papas des wokes, le juge vient r
exexemple, qui parle de racisme
sysystémique. À un moment donné,
ilil y a une réalité envers les
auautochtones au Québec qui est
didifficile.
- - Les autochtones, c'est un cs
spspécial, vous avez raison.
- - On est dans une dynamique
popolitique. Le premier ministre
dudu Québec ne peut pas
rereconnaître le racisme
sysystémique, parce que c'est le
fafait pour les autochtones, ila
êêtre condamné à le faire pour
totous les autres.
- - Oui, mais il devrait justemt
lele faire pour tous les autres.
J'J'arrive pas à comprendre
cocomment le Québec serait la
seseule société qui est à l'abri
dede ça. Christian, est-ce que e
pepeux terminer. Il n'y a pas de
hohonte à avouer qu'on a problèe
dede cet ordre-là est le meiller
momoyen de commencer le régler,
c'c'est de le reconnaître. Rédue
çaça à racisme individuel, saigr
lele problème. Quand on a proble
avavec la justice, la police, le
lologement, l'emploi et le syste
dede santé, ça commence à être s
mamal systémique.
- - C'est une dynamique nord-
amaméricaine. En Europe, racisme
sysystémique est très contesté.
LeLes gens qui contestent ça,
c'c'est pas des innocents. On st
quque c'est pas juste individuel
mamais on est conscient que c'et
unun concept très marqué
cuculturellement lié à une culte
nonord-américaine.
- - Bref, ça existe mais il ne
fafaut pas le dire.
- - Un autre débat. Je vous fais
enentendre les manufacturiers qi
lalancent 1/1000 cri d'alarme en
didisant qu'il m'en demande et s
veveulent monter laisser des
mimigrations pour amener des
trtravailleurs davantage au
QuQuébec.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE,
chcheffe, Parti libéral du Québc
- - Le premier ministre s'est lé
cocombien de fois pour parler
dede l'importance de produire
auau Québec? Ce sont
ceces manufacturiers Québécois
ququi sont en train de s'adressr
àà lui en lui disant qu'ils ont
bebesoin de son soutien.
- - Les manufacturiers et le
PaParti libéral veulent augmentr
lele nombre d'immigrants. Nous,
onon pense que le Québec a attet
sasa capacité d'immigration.
- - Alors, capacité d'd'intégran
atatteinte?
- - Qui a décidé ça? Est-ce qu'l
y y a une étude, est-ce qu'il ya
unune commission d'enquête? Non,
c'c'est ce que Monsieur Legault
didit. Ça s'appelle une opinion.
C'C'est celle de Monsieur Legaut
ilil y en a beaucoup d'autres, y
cocompris celles des
mamanufacturiers qui sont
inintervenus aujourd'hui. Quande
prpremier ministre lance de façn
pépéremptoire que le Québec a
atatteint sa capacité d'absorptn
paparce que moi, je le sais et e
lele dis. C'est pas comme ça que
çaça se passe normalement dans e
dédémocratie.
- - Le Québec par rapport à sa
popopulation est une des sociéts
au m monde qui reçoit les plus
d'd'immigrants. Il y a juste
l'l'Australie qui nous dépasse.n
rereçoit beaucoup d'immigrants,
plplus que la France et les Éta-
UnUnis par rapport à la
popopulation. Le problème est ts
réréel. Je suis à la baie Saint-
PaPaul il y a quelques jours etn
nene pouvait pas aller déjeuner
paparce que les restaurants n'ot
papas de main-d'oeuvre. C'est ts
coconcret, le problème est réel.
MoMoi, la capacité d'intégration
dudu Québec, je ne sous-estime s
çaça, entre autres sur le plan
lilinguistique. On a souvent
esessayé d'assimiler le québécos
frfrancophone par assimilation.
LaLa solution, je ne l'ai pas.
- - Je suis assez d'accord avec
MoMonsieur Legault et je pense
ququ'on ne peut pas réduire
l'l'immigration à un problème
écéconomique. Ça fait parti d'un
enensemble au moment où le
gogouvernement, on débat à
l'l'Assemblée nationale en
cocommission parlementaire d'un
prprojet de loi qui essaie de
frfreiner l'anglicisation, il ya
plplusieurs aspects à
l'l'immigration. Il y a un
prproblème de pénurie de main-
d'd'oeuvre, mais je pense pas
ququossé les seuils d'immigratin
sosois une solution absolument
papas. Monsieur Fitzgibbon a
raraison. Il y a une partie du
prproblème qui peut être réglé r
lala requalification de la main-
d'd'oeuvre. Réduire ça à un
prproblème de migration, je troe
quque c'est tout à fait passé à
ccôté de l'ensemble de la
prproblématique du français au
QuQuébec.
- - Autre sujet, qui va relancer
leles débats sur les champs de
cocompétences. Monsieur Trudeau
pepersiste et signe. Si vous
pepensiez qu'il n'y aurait pas
trtrop de conditions et qu'il
alallait augmenter les transfers
ininconditionnels aux provinces,
vovoici ce qu'il a plutôt dit.
- - Est-ce que vous comptez
gogouverner pendant quatre ans
sasans déclencher des élections?
- - J'espère. Certainement
quque les Canadiens ont donné
dedes indications qu'ils voulait
unun gouvernement qui travaille
susur les grands enjeux
enen partenariat avec d'autres.
EtEt c'est exactement
cece que nous allons faire.
- - Vous aurez compris que c'étt
papas tout à fait celle-là, mais
c'c'est intéressant aussi...
l'l'autre, c'est sur les
coconditions des transferts en
sasanté.
- - On va être là pour augmenter
leles transferts en santé envers
l'l'province déjà de maçon pourn
didiscuter. Comme j'ai aussi dit
pependant les élections, nous ns
atattendons à un niveau de
trtransparence et de relais de
vivisibilité. Ça ne sera pas sas
cocondition, mais on va discuter
avavec l'province comment nous
alallons pouvoir nous assurer qe
leles gens à travers le pays
rereçoive les services nécessais
avavec les investissements
dcdcontribuable.
- - Ça ne sera pas sans conondi.
- - C'est absolument pas
susurprenant. Monsieur Trudeau t
coconséquent avec lui-même. Il a
totoujours dit ça. On aurait pu
esespérer qu'après l'élection,
MoMonsieur Trudeau est encore
miminoritaire, on aurait pu
esespérer mais honnêtement, je
m'm'attendais pas à ça. Je
vovoudrais revenir un peu sur la
prpremière partie de la clip qun
a a passé, Monsieur Trudeau a dt
ququ'il espère, mais à une autre
ququestion elle a répondu : si e
gogouvernement n'est pas renver.
UnUn gouvernement peut toujoursn
momoment donné mettre un espècee
pipilule empoisonnée dans un
bubudget ou un projet de loi por
fafaire en sorte que l'oppositin
nene puisse pas l'accepter le
rerenverser. La promesse de
MoMonsieur Trudeau, enfin, le
neneveu de Monsieur Trudeau, il
popourrait facilement lui-même
fafaire en sorte qu'il ne se
réréalise pas.
- - Mais on sent qu'il y a quand
mmême eu un message de passer pr
l'l'électorat canadien assez
clclair.
- - Sur les conditions, c'est un
vivieux discours dépassé qui avt
sasa raison d'être si ça avait é
vrvrai, sur le fait que certains
prpromesses ne dépensaient pas
totout l'argent qu'ils reçoivent
dudu fédéral. Le fédéral a
tetellement baissé sa contributn
quque vous pouvez être absolumet
cecertaine que chaque sou que le
féfédéral envoi pour la santé et
dédépensé en santé. L'épreuve
ininscrite au secours de façon
ununanime. Ce que Monsieur
TrTrudeau, c'est un vieux discos
etet ça n'a plus sa raison d'êt.
LeLe chèque se fait au fonds
coconsolidé et c'est le fonds
coconsolidé qui paie la santé et
c'c'est correct. Il n'y a plus
pepersonne au Canada qui il y a
ququelqu'un qui pense que les
prprovinces servent de ça pour
babaisser les impôts quoique ce
sosoit.
- - Est-ce que les provinces ont
lele gros bout du bâton ou si
c'c'est Monsieur Trudeau qui a e
grgros bout du bâton?
- - Il a l'avantage d'avoir dit
clclairement qu'il poserait des
coconditions. J'aimerais croiree
quque vient de dire MiMichel C
AuAuger, mais il est arrivé
ququelque chose dans la crise
sasanitaire au Québec, c'est que
QuQuébec a failli dans les CHSLD
onon a demandé l'aide de l'armé.
J'J'écoutais la conférence de
prpresse de Monsieur Trudeau, il
n'n'y avait rien de nouveau. Un
jojournaliste lui a demandé s'iy
avavait un élément nouveau danse
prprochain mandat il n'a pas été
cacapable d'en donner un. Je pee
quque l'élément nouveau, c'est
ququ'il annonce une offensive
féfédérale dans les champs de
cocompétences provinciaux. Il ea
paparlé dans la campagne il
pepersiste et signe. Est-ce qu'l
y y aura des élections pas d'ici
ququatre ans, c'est facile de de
ququelque chose, des promesses
d'd'ivrogne. Dans six mois, dans
unun an, le contexte peut
tetellement changer. Je trouvais
quque Monsieur Trudeau s'est
dédépassé. C'est un adepte de la
lalangue de bois mais aujourd'h,
ilil s'est dépassé. Il n'y avait
ririen de nouveau.
- - Michel David, vous avez fait
unune chronique, j'ai relu le
tititre de fois. Est-ce que
LeLegault est pire que TrudeauÇa
sese peut pas. Mais vous parleze
lala clarté, Monsieur Trudeau a
dédéchiré sa promesse de réformr
lele mode de scrutin et la fête
clclairement. Vous dîtes que
LeLegault fait ça mais ne le dit
papas.
- - M. Legault a été clair et
cycynique parce qu'il dit que le
sysystème a produit un
gogouvernement que les gens aimt
alalors le garde. Son gouvernemt
àà lui. Monsieur Trudeau s'était
enengagé.... M. Legault dit ence
ququ'il veut le faire, mais
coconcrètement, les organismes
babancaires ça ne se fasse pas.e
prprojet de loi, qu'on soit pour
ouou contre, c'est plus l'éthiqe
popolitique de Monsieur Legault
quque je discute ici. Monsieur
LeLegault, honnêtement, il faitn
sosorte que son projet de loi ne
sesera pas adopté avant la fin..
lele référendum, il est déjà
acacquis qui ne pourra pas y en
avavoir à l'élection. Mais il ny
auaura peut-être même pas de
prprojet de loi avant l'élection
etet après ça, il va mourir.
- - Christian, vous êtes contrea
réréforme du mode de scrutin. Ms
unun peu de clarté?
- - Je trouve l'article de Michl
trtrès intéressant. Je sentais
bebeaucoup d'indignation. Mais
heheureusement, il ne semble pas
crcroire que la réforme du modee
scscrutin aura lieu, ce qui
MoMoravie. On n'est pas en mora,
onon est en politique. C'est une
prpromesse électorale mal avisée
etet Monsieur Legault revient l-
dedessus et c'est tant mieux